ادى ضباط من الدفعه السادسه بعد المئه من
الكليه العسكريه الاولى في العراق قسم
التخرج داخل مرقد الامام الحسين في مدينه
كربلاء جنوب بغداد وقد جاء اداء القسم
الذي اعقب تخريجهم الرسمي وسط هتافات
مذهبيه في مشهد مخالف للاعراف والتقاليد
العسكريه في
العراق
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الاعزاء كان هذا خبر
حلقتنا ونناقش فيما وراءه ما الذي دعى
هؤلاء الضباط الى اعاده اداء القسم في
مرقد الحسين وما مدى انسجام هذا السلوك مع
معايير المؤسسه العسكريه العراقيه ما
التاثيرات المحتمله لهذه الخطوه على صوره
الجيش العراقي كمؤسسه وطنيه يفترض فيها
اخذ مسافه متساويه من جميع مكونات
البلاد
في حفل مهيب حضره رئيس اركان الجيش
العراقي الفريق اول ركن عثمان الغانمي
ممثل القائد العام للقوات المسلحه احتفل
ضباط الدفعه السادسه بعد المئه بتخريج من
الكليه العسكريه العراقيه يوم الجمعه
الماضي وادوا قسم الولاء للعراق حسب
تقاليد المؤسسه العسكريه العريقه لكن
الحفل الذي صادف ايضا احتفال الكليه
العسكريه بالذكرى ال6 لتاسيس لم يكن كافيا
فيما يبدو لهؤلاء الضباط او لبعضهم ما
دعاهم لاعاده اداء قسم الولاء لكن في مزار
طائفي هذه المره تقرير مريم
ابيش عاهد الله
والهد الله ونعاه السيدي ومولاي ونعاه
السيدي ومولاي الامام الحسين عليه السلام
الامام الحسين عليه السلام قسم غير وارد
في الدستور العراقي وفي قلب حرم مرق ق
الامام الحسين بكربلاء اتت بهؤلاء الضباط
المتخرجين رسميا وحديثا من المؤسسه
العسكريه ما تعرف بالعتبه العباسيه مؤسسه
دينيه شيعيه تنظم الزيارات الى مراقد ال
البيت سبق وان احتفلت هذه الدفعه التي
سميت بشائر النصر بتخرجها من الكليه
العسكريه الذي تزامن مع الذكرى ال6 لتاسيس
الجيش العراقي بيد ان المراسم التي نظمت
لاحقا في مرقد الامام الحسين اث جدلا
كبيرا وانتقادات الكثيرين بشان عقيده
الجيش العراقي اهي للوطن ام للمذهب من
اكبر الازمات التي ورثها العراق من الغزو
الامريكي وسياسات رئيس الوزراء السابق نور
المالكي هي غياب جيش وطني قوي وبالرغم من
الجهود التي بذلها رئيس الوزراء الحالي
حيدر العبادي والحديث عن ضغط امريكي من
اجل تصحيح اخطائ وخطايا المالك لا تبدو
المهمه سهله ولا ممكنه في اوجه الحرب على
تنظيم الدوله حدث ذلك في كل مراحل الحرب
على التنظيم واخرها معركه الموصل الحاليه
فمنذ الايام الاولى لهذه المعركه كانت
الشعارات والرايات الطائفيه حاضره وبقوه
ما دفع البعض للتساؤل اهي معركه من اجل
العراق المتعدد الاعراق والاديان والمذاهب
ام من اجل اجنده طائفيه تخدم مذهبا دون
غيره حتى قوات البيشمركه منعت في بدايه
المعركه لوائين للجيش العراقي من عبور
منطقه مخمور كان السبب رفع تلك القوات
رايات طائفيه رفضت انزالها من الاليات
العسكريه عندما طلبت القوات الكرديه منها
ذلك علما بان فقره في الدستور العراقي تنص
على ان المؤسسه العسكريه يجب ان تضم جميع
المكونات من مسلمين ومسيحيين واكراد
وتركمان وطوائف واثني بلا تمييز بين ما هو
مكتوب وما هو موجود فرق جلي دخول ميليشيا
الحش الشعبيه المشهد بشكل شرعي تحت رايه
الحرب على تنظيم الدوله زاد الطين بالله
بعض التقارير تحدثت عن تسريب ما لا يقل عن
12 جندي في الجيش النظامي والتحاقهم
بالمليشيا لاهداف ماديه ومذهب اكبر
الحركات والويه التي تحمل السلاح تحت مظله
الحشد تعلن ولائها لمرجعيات ايرانيه جهرا
وعلنا احد اسباب التاخير المستمر لحسم
معركه الموصل وهذا التداخل بين المؤسسات
والسلطات الرسميه والدينيه والحزبيه اما
التدخل الاقليمي والاجنبي فذلك موضوع اخر
لا يقل خطوره على مستقبل البلاد اللهم صل
على محمد وال محمد جيش بلا عقيده قتاليه
وطنيه وبولا للطائفه وليس للوطن قد يعني
ضياع وطن كاني مكان في العراق جيش هو
الاقوى في المنطقه والخامس في العالم
حقيقه ربما ستبقى حبيسه شيف اذا استمرت
الامور بهذا
الشكل موضوع حلقتنا اليوم نناقشه مع ضيفين
من بغداد عضو ائتلاف دوله القانون عدنان
السراج ومن اسطنبول الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي السيد حاتم كريم الفلاحي
مرحبا بكما وسؤالنا للسيد
السراج سيد عدنان كثيرا ما يعني تدرع
المدافعون عن تصرفات المؤسسات العراقيه
وبخاصه الجيش والشرطه ازاء الاتهامات
بالمذهب والطائفيه بان هذه مجرد تصرفات
فرديه وليست مؤسسيه الان بدا الامر وكانه
مؤسسي وبدا وكان هناك تقنين لمساله المذهب
والطائفه في العراق والولاء للطائفه
والمذهب وليس للوطن هل هناك ما يمكن ان
يرد به على هذه الحجه يعني في البدايه خلي
نقول بشكل واضح هل بمعنى انه انتماء هؤلاء
للمذهب الشيعي وانتماء مؤسسه عسكريه يعني
التخلي عن المذهب الشيعي لصالح اي امر اخر
لن ينص الدستور على ان يكون الجيش العراقي
ان يتخلى الجندي او الضابط او اي يعني
منتسب للقوات المسلحه والشرطه ان يتخلى عن
مذهبه او قوميته او ما شبه ذلك وبالتالي
اعتقد اليوم ما تم تصويره بهذا الشكل
اعتقد قد بلغ فيه على اساس انه مؤسسه
طائفيه الامام الحسين ليس طائفيا الامام
الحسين هو لكل المسلمين وبالتالي هو وقدوه
حسنه لكل العراقيين سنه وشيعه وهذا
التقليد الذي شفناه ووجدناه اليوم هو ليس
ترديد القسم الحسين ليس خاصا بالشيعه فقط
وليس محترما ولا مبجلا عند الشيعه فقط لكن
المسلمين بصفه عامه يعتقدون ان علي رضي
الله عنه هو رمز اهم وافضل من الحسين وان
محمدا صلى الله عليه وسلم جد الامام
الحسين هو افضل من الحسين نفسه ويمكن ان
يتخذ هؤلاء رموزا ترضي كافه الاطياف وكافه
المذاهب في الع
العراق في العراق في العراق لدينا تقاليد
هذه تقاليد لعلك يعني لا تعرف ثقافه
العراقيين بشكل عام نحن نقول الذين
يحتفلون بتخر المناسبه هذا ليس شرطا انا
اعرف منطق الاشياء وليس بالضروره اعرف
التقاليد التقاليد العسكريه لا خل خلي خلي
خلي اكمل خلي اكفي لك الفكره يعني يعني لا
اريد ان تكفي الفكره خليني انا انت سالتني
وخليني اجاوبك على قد الفكره اليوم مساله
الامام الحسين والعباس وحتى الشيخ عبد
القادر الجيلاني في بغداد هناك حتى
السياسيون تقليد معروف فيصل اخذ وزرائه
الى العباس وحلفه هناك القاده العسكريين
لكل الانقلابات العسكريه وقضيه السيد احمد
حسن البكر رئيس الجمهوريه واخذه لصدام
حسين وبقيه اعضاء مجلس قياده الثوره الى
العباس للحلف هناك بان يكونوا يعني اقوياء
ويكونوا وحده واحده ويحافظوا على الوطن
هذا التقليد موجود وليس بشيء غريب على
العراقيين اطلاقا اقول اليوم التخرج تم في
الكليه العسكريه الدوره 106 التي يقودها
اللواء حامد الزهيري هؤلاء اغلبهم من
السنه وبالتالي من ذهب الى الامام الحسين
هم خريجو ذي قار اي الناصريه وبالتالي
لديهم كل الحريه بان يذهبوا ويجدد العهد
امام القدوه وهو الامام الحسين عليه افضل
الصلاه والسلام على عنوان شخصيه شخصيه
الامام الحسين مؤثر فيهم ويمكن من خلاله
ان يعطوا العهد الاخر بانهم سوف يسيرون
على طريق الحسين ح سي حاتميه لا اعتقد
فيها التباس سيد حاتم الفلاحي ما عفوا سيد
حاتم الفلاحي ما المشكله اذا اذا كان هذا
تقليدا في العراق ان يذهب الضباط الى مرقد
الامام الحسين رضي الله عنه ويعادون او
يقسمون بالعهد والولاء للحسين بانهم
سيدافعون عن المقدسات العراقيه ما المشكله
في هذا اذا كان هذا اذا كانت هذه هي السنه
الجاريه في
بلدكم نعم تحيه لك ولضيفك الكريم ومشاهدي
قناه الجزيره اولا ا انا اعتقد باننا
نتكلم اليوم عن جيش الدوله وجيش النظام
والان جيش الطائفه يعني التقسيمات سابقا
كانت تقسم الى جيشين جيش الدوله وهو الجيش
الوطني وجيش النظام اللي هو الجيش الي
دافع عن شله معينه في نظام معين مثل ما
يجري الان في سوريا والان بدانا نتكلم عن
جيش يخص الطائفه هذا الجيش بدا ترتيبه في
العراق منذ فتره طويله جدا انا عندما
اتكلم يتكلم الان الضيف عن عن عن احمد حسن
البكر هل قام احمد حسن البكر او اي احد من
القاده العراقيين باخذ مجموعه من الضباط
بهذا القدر الى الحسين او الى مناطق اخرى
من العراق لاداء القسم الم يكن اداء القسم
في الكليه العسكريه العراقيه من عنذ عام
1921 والى اليوم وينتهي الامر لماذا هذه
لماذا هذه الاشياء بدات تظهر لدينا تظهر
بعد الاحتلال عام 2003 انا اشير انه في
عام 2008 عندما جاء كانت صوره الفرسان في
البصره الفرقه 14 لم تمتثل لاوامر القائد
العام للقوات المسلحه لانها كانت تنتمي
الى التيار الصدري وحزب الفضيله وما جرى
من اوامر من القياده العامه للقوات
المسلحه لم تنفذ وتم تبديل هذه الفرقه على
اثر هذه الحادثه في البصره اضف الى هذا
بان هناك كثير من المشاهد الطائفيه التي
تطغى على الجيش العراقي الان نحن لو نتكلم
عن العقيده العسكريه ما هي العقيده
العسكريه الان للجيش العقيده لو تكلمنا عن
الحشد الشعبي الان الحشد الشعبي يعتبر
مؤسسه عسكريه مع وزاره الدفاع العراقيه
وبالتالي نحن نتكلم عن جيوش متعدده نتكلم
عن جيش اسس بنفس طائفي منذ البدايه
بمحاسبه طائفيه جاء بها المحتل الامريكي
وهو يتحمل الان ما يجري في العراق لم يكن
هذا النفس موجود لا بدورات التخرج ولا
بكافه التفاصيل الموجوده الجيش الكان كان
جيش وطني يمتثل لاوامر القياده العامه
للقوات المسلحه فقط لكن الان نرى بان هذا
الجيش ياتمر باوامر كثيره ومتعدده وما جرى
عند المنطقه الخضراء عندما جاء رجل الدين
الدخول للمنطقه الخضراء ضابط برتبه فريق
ركن ياتي ليقبل رجل يد رجل هذا الدين اذا
نحن نتكلم عن ولاءات لاشخاص طائفيين نتكلم
بولاء طائفه معينه على حساب بقيه الطوائف
عندما خرجت المناطق السنيه للتظاهر في عام
2014 كانت من اهم النقاط التي طرحها بانه
لا توجد هناك توازن في مؤسسات الدوله من
ضمنها مؤسسه الجيش والاجهزه الامنيه عندما
نتكلم عن محاصصه طائفيه فهذه المحاصه سنتي
على ذكر انعكاسات هذه الخطوه على صوره
الجيش العراقي ولكن في النصف الثاني من
هذه الحلقه سيد عدنان السراج الجيش
العراقي لا يحتوي فقط المكون المكونين
السني والشيعي هناك مسيحيون هناك يزيدي
يفترض ان الجيش لكل مكونات الدوله
العراقيه ماذا يصنع الذين لا يعتقدون اصلا
في الحسين الذين لا يعتقدون في الاسلام
كعقيدة
والتقى بالمرجع في داخل مرقد امير
المؤمنين وهناك تعهد امام المرجع بانه
سيكون وفيا للعراق وهذه واقعه تاريخيه
احمد حسن بكر اخذ صدام حسين
وحردانة الى شيخ عبد القادر الجيلاني يذهب
الى الامام العباس الى الامام الحسين قضيه
لا علاقه لها بالمؤسسه العسكريه ولا
بالافراد من يريد ان يذهب فليذهب ومن يريد
لا يذهب لا يذهب فذلك نقول لي المؤسسه
العسكريه
كيوم المؤسسه العسكريه الذي يشهد تجاوزات
طائفيه عفوا عفوا الذي يشهد تجاوزات
طائفيه هائله في مدن كثيره من التي جرى
كما يقال تحريرها وانتزاعها من ايدي تنظيم
الدوله الاسلاميه و اثر رايه الشديده التي
تجري في العراق فان هذا الامر لا ياتي
خارجا عن السياق العام ولكن يؤكد هذه
الفكره الفكره التي تشير الى طائفيه هذه
المؤسسات عقب او فيما
يس اسمع هذا الكلام هنا فقط بس اسمعني انا
اسمع كلام فق الجيش
العراق بس اسمعني اخي العزيز خل اكفي
الفكره ارجوك يعني
تسمح يعني اما ان استمع لك ونحن طائفيون
او انت تسمع مني حتى ارد التهمه يعني هذا
انصاف بالعداله وبالمهل يا اخي العزيز
خليني اكمل الفكره وانت اخذ ما حصتك في
اقول اليوم الجيش العراقي في حربه لتحرير
المدن هل ظهر له تصرف طائفي هل بين ان هذا
الجيش العراقي يتصرف تصرفا طائفيا على
العكس من ذلك اقول اليوم الجيش العراقي
فيه السنه والشيعه والمسيحيين والاكراد
وكل طاف يتصرف بمهنيه كعسكري اما كمعتقل
ايس لنا دخل على اي انسان في معتقداته او
يعبر عن ولائه او يعبر عن نجاحه او فرحته
ها قضيه يعني تعتبر شخصيه ولا علاقه لها
بالمؤسسه العسكريه بالمطلق اقول اليوم
الحرب التي يقودها الجيش العراقي حرب
نظيفه وليس هناك اي شك بان الجيش العراقي
الان يقوم حرب نظيفه ويتعامل مع بمنت ايضا
امر شخصي وانه ليس هناك تاثير على عقيده
الجيش وع على ممارسات الجيش والدليل على
ذلك سلوك الجيش المنضبط في المدن التي جرى
تحريرها او التي يجري تحريرها في اللحظه
التي نتحدث نحن فيها الان ماذا يحدث اذا
ذهب كل ضابط وكل جندي في الجيش العراقي
امام المرجعيه التي ينتمي اليها واقسم مثل
هذا القسم وادى الولاء احدهم لخالد بن
الوليد والاخر ليزيد بن معاويه والثالث
لمعاويه والرابع لابي سفيان وهكذا ماذا
يحدث في الجيش العراقي
كمؤسسه نعم اخي هذا الكلام لذر الرمات في
العيون يعني عندما يتكلم عن الملك فيصل
هذا تصرف شخصي لا يمكن ان يعكس ينعكس هذا
التصرف الشخصي على المؤسسه العسكريه طيب ل
يعطني مثال من الحكم السابق بانه دوره من
الدورات ذهبت اعداد باعداد كبيره مثل هذه
الاعداد ووقفت مثل هذه الوقفه وادت هذا
القسم بهذا الترتيب علما بانه العراق بعد
2003 يختلف عن العراق قب قبل هذه السنوات
قبل الاحتلال اضف الى هذا عندما يقول لاي
يقول لا يوجد هناك تغيير ديموغرافي انا
احيل ل الى الى الى الى الى رئيس الى رئيس
مجلس محافظه صلاح الدين احمد الكريم قبل
ايام تكلم بان التغيير ديمغرافي لحد هذه
اللحظه ميليشيات الحشد الشعبي تمنع الناس
من الرجوع الى الى منازلها لم يتم ارجاع
جرف الصخر لم يتم ارجاع كثير من العوائل
في دياله وكثير من القرى لم يتم ارجاع
كثير من الناس في محافظه صلاح الدين وخاصه
في بيجي وتكريت ومناطق اخرى في سلمان بيج
ومناطق اخرى وتتكلم تقول لا يوجد تغيير
ديموغرافي اذا اين انتم من هذه الامور اذا
الا تعلمون بانه هناك كثير من الامور تجري
ولا علم لكم بها اضف الى هذا عندما يتكلم
الان يتكلم يقول الجيش ليس طائفي من افتعل
مجزره الحويجه من الذي قتل اكثر من 200
شخص 250 شخص في الحويجه بنفس سني ولم يكن
هناك اي قطعه سلاح داخل داخل المظاهرات
الذين خرجوا بصدور عاريه من قتل اهل
الفلوجه من قتل 700 واكثر اكثر من 700 شخص
في معركه الفلوجه من الذي اخذ 1200 شخص ال
ط لست ادري ان كان لد ضيفنا اجابات على
هذه الاسئله لكن سنستمع اليه في ما بعد
الفاصل القصير ونناقش بعد هذا الفاصل
تاثير اداء ضباط عراقيين القسم في مزار
طائفي على صوره الجيش العراقي وحياديته
الوطنيه نرجو ان تبقوا
معنا
اهلا بكم مجددا مشاهدينا الاعزاء في هذه
الحلقه التي تناقش ابعاد ودلالات اداء
ضباط من خريجي الكليه العسكريه العراقيه
القسم في مزار طائفي بمدينه كرب بلاء
واعود بالسؤال لضيفنا من بغداد السيد
عدنان السراج عضو اتلاف دوله القانون سيد
عدنان لعلك استمعت الى بعض الاسئله التي
طرحها ضيفنا السيد حاتم الفلاحي هل لديك
ما يمكن ان تجيب به عن هذه
الاسئله يعني انا استغرب بهذا النفس انا
اريد اقول من قتل الشيعه في سوق الصدريه
1000 واحد من قتل الشيعه في جسر الائمه
الف واحد سقطوا في المياه وغرقوا قتل
الشيعه بين بين بين سلوك عفوا قبل قبل ان
تسترسل فقط في هذه الاسئله عفوا قبل ان
تسترسل في هذه الاسئله هناك فارق بين سلوك
هناك فارق بين سلوك جماعات غير منضبطه
وفارق بين مؤسسات او سلوك مؤسسات الدوله
المنضبط التي يفترض ان تكون مختلفه عن
سلوك الجماع لا ما الفرق بين داعش كما
تقول وبين الجيش العراقي او الحشد
الشعبي اتركه هو يجيب حبيبي لماذا لم تجيب
انترك يجيب
هذا انت عد تجيب نيابه عنك لا تريد الاجاب
معقوله يعني هكذا يصير انا انا في حيره من
امري عموما انا اقول هذا النفس الطائفي من
قتل الشيعه هم الارهابيون الطائفيون ومن
يقتل السنه ايضا هؤلاء الطائفيون
الارهابيون بنفس الطريقه فلذلك لا ينسب اي
عمل الى العراقي الوطني النظيف ولا الى
الجندي ولا لحشد ولا اي انسان يقاتل من
اجل وطنه ومن اجل مصلحه وطنه كل من يقتل
بهذا النفس فهو طائف
هناك الالوف بل الملايين من الشيعه قد
قتلوا بدم بارد على طريق الرمادي الرطبه
ذبح المئات بل الالوف من الشيعه عوائلهم
ونسائهم واطفالهم بالالوف في المشاهده في
الطارميه في جرف الصخر في اللطيفيه كان
ينزل الانسان ويذبح على عنوان الشيعي نحن
لا نتكلم عن هذا المنطق هذا المنطق قد وى
نحن نقول اليوم هذا الجيش وجيش وطني
وبالتالي نقول كل تفسير طائفي لاي حاله هو
امر امر مرفوض بالمناسبه مزار الحسين ليس
مزارا طائفيا الامام الحسين امام وهو سيد
شباب اهل الجنه امامان ان قام او قعده
فهما امامان وليس بمرقد طائفي بالمناسبه
هو لكل المسلمين وهو ابن رسول الله ابن
بنت رسول الله فلذلك عندما نقول مزار
طائفي هذا تسويق لقضيه طائفيه بحته انا
اقول اليوم الزياره الى الامام الحسين
سيدي نحن نحن تعرضنا لهذه النقطه في بدايه
الحلقه وقلت لك ولا اظنك تختلف معي جد
الامام الحسين واعظم منه شانا وان وان
اباه علي رضي الله عنه واعظم منه شانا
فبالتالي اذا كنت تتحدث عن مزار او رمز
بالنسبه للمسلمين لكي يثير فيهم الحميه
ويصير لهم قدوه فهناك الكثير من الاماكن
الاخرى التي يمكن اقسم فيها عف عف حت الح
في هذا
السجال حاتم الفلاحي الثيرات المحتمله على
صوره الجيش العراقي وحياد هذه المؤسسه في
ظل مثل هذه
الممارسات نعم بدايه انا اقول بانه من
يمسك زمام الحكم في العراق هم الشيعه الان
في العراق وبقيه الاطراف الموجوده هو
عباره عن اكمال ديكور سواء كانوا من السنه
او من الاكراد اما مفاصل الدوله بالاجهزه
الامنيه وكافه الاجهزه الاخرى من يتحكم
فيها يتحكمون فيها الشيعه من يحاسب على
قتل هؤلاء الابرياء نحن نحاسب الدوله على
قل هؤلاء لانكم انتم من تمسكون بزمام
الامور وانتم من تتحكمون في البلد سواء
كان بوزاره الدفاع او الداخليه دوله تبقى
بدون وزير دفاع وبدون وزاره داخليه لمده
اربع سنوات في زمن المالكي من يتحمل هذه
المسؤوليه يتحملها القائد العام للقوات
المسلحه وعندما ياتي ياتي حيدر العبادي
الان ايضا وزاره دفاع ووزاره داخليه بدون
وزير دفاع وبدون وبدون كثير من التفاصيل
الاخرى التي يجب ان تكون متكامله لغرض عمل
هذه الاجهزه انتم تتحملون الفشل الامني
والفشل العسكري في العراق لانكم بنيتم هذه
المؤسسات على اسس طائفيه من خلال من خلال
المحاصصه الطائفيه التي جاء بها المحتل
والذين مشت جميع التكتلات السياسيه في هذا
الركب وعملتم على بناء هذه المؤسسه
بمحاصرته الحرفيه والمهنيه في هذا الجيش
وبالتالي اليوم ما يجري من تداعيات على
هذه المؤسسه العسكريه من يتحملها تتحملها
الاحزاب الحاكمه التي حكمت العراق بالفتره
السابقه ويتحملها المحتل الامريكي طيب من
وجه نظر سياسيه سيد حاتم كريم الفحي ع
عفوا سيد حاتم من وجهه نظر
سياسيه هل هل تبدو لك الصوره وكان هناك
اصرار على اظهار التقاليد المذهبيه في بعض
المؤسسات لربط مصائر وارزاق الناس في
العراق بهذه بهذا المذهب هل تعتقد ان هذه
يمكن ان تكون لها ابعاد سياسيه مساله
اعلان طائفيه الدوله العراقيه حتى لا يكون
هناك مجال للتوظيف وا الاسترزاق الا من
خلال السير في ركاب هذه التصرفات او هذه
المؤسسات
المذهبيه ابدا هذا هذا الامر له ما بعده
هذا الامر له ما بعده بان البلد ستكون
عقيدته القادمه عقيده شيعيه كامله لن يكون
هناك شيء للمكونات الاخرى وما يجري الان
من تشكيل الحشد الشعبي بنفس طائفي من
الشيعه فقط هو دليل وخير دليل على ما نقول
من سيطره على الاجهزه الامنيه علما بان
هذه الميليشيات التي تم تشكيل الحشد منها
قد دمجت في عام 2004 بقرار 91 في في زمن
برايمر بدمجها ضمن الجيش العراقي طيب اذا
كان هذه الميليشيات دمجت كيف ظهرت هذه
الميليشيات الان علما انها ظهرت في عام
2012 باستعراض كامل لهذه الميليشيات من
عصائب ومن بدر وما الى ذلك واليوم سيقومون
بتشكيل الحشد الشعبي وستبقى هذه
الميليشيات خارج اطار الدوله ستعمل هذه
المؤسسه تحت انظار قيادات الحشد الشعبي
وسيكون هناك ميليشيات اخرى لن تظهر الى
العلم وسنتعامل مع دوله داخل الدوله بصوره
طائفيه متكامله وصلنا الى ختام هذه الحلقه
عفوا على المقاطعه اشكرك شكرا جزيلا
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي حاتم كريم
الفلاحي كان ضيفنا من اسطنبول واشكر ضيفنا
من بغداد عضو ائتلاف دوله القانون عدنان
السراج مشاهدينا الاعزاء نهايه هذهه
الحلقه من برنامج ما وراء الخبر نلتقي
باذن الله تعالى في قراءه جديده في ما
وراء خبر جديد السلام عليكم ورحمه
[موسيقى]
الله ه